تتذكروا قبل الجوله الاولى كان هنالك
تصريحات من حزب الشعب الجمهوري والزعيمي
كمال كالجار عندما كان ينادي الشعب
الازمات والمشكلات والعراقيل هي العنوان
ابرز للجوله الاولى ويجب عليكم الا تخرجوا
الى الشوارع والساحات الميادين وكان يحضر
عليهم الخروج لم تكن هنالك اي مشكلات فيها
الجوله الاولى الجوله الثانيه مره اخرى هي
خاليه من الازمات والمشكلات والعراقيل
ورويدا رويدا نحصل على نسب مئويه جميعنا
ننتظر مع بعضنا بعض مره اخرى لاراده
الوطنيه
تتجسد وستكون تاج على رؤوسنا محترمه من
قبلنا مره اخرى اقول بان خلق اجواء
القلق
والتوتر هي من عادات حزب الشعب الجمهوري
الى عدم وضع تركيا
وشعبنا في هذه الاجواء الاراده الوطنيه
تحترم من قبل تحترم من قبل جميع تعطيها في
شعبنا الى الان النسبه المئويه لصالح رجب
طيب ولكن لم يخرج اي ممثل عن حزب العداله
والتنميه ليعلنا بان السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان متفوق او ما شابه ذلك من التعبير
هذه الايام هو ايام الاحترام
والتقدير للانتخابات وان هذه
التصريحات ستكون
عناوين موجوده ومحفوره على
جباهنا بغض النظر عن
انتخابكم واختياراتكم لاي شخص كان
الاحترام هو العنوان الابرز مره اخرى ادعو
جميع
اطياف شعبنا الى الهدوء وان يكونوا
مرتاحين الضبابيه هي تاتي من مركز حزب
الشعب الجمهوري وان كفوا عن هذه الضبابيه
والتضليل لا توجد هنالك اي اوساط تخلق هذه
الضبابيه مره اخرى اشكر جميع اطيافه شعبيه
الى توجههم الى الانتخابات واتمنى ان تكون
وسيله خير وسلاما تعم على هذه الدوله
لمتابعه المزيد
من البرامج وال
قصص لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات